so many things go wrong when you're
starting a company and often I think
people ask you know what mistakes should
you avoid making my answer that is don't
even bother trying to avoid mistakes
because you're gonna make tons of
mistakes
the important thing is actually learning
quickly from whatever mistakes you make
and not giving up there are things every
single year of Facebook's existence that
could have killed us or made it so that
it just seemed like moving forward and
making a lot of progress just seemed
intractable but you just kind of bounce
back and you learn and nothing is
impossible you just have to keep running
through the walls
I don't hire people who I wouldn't work
for myself like that's a really good
heuristic because everyone knows this
like there's no saying like a player's
hire a players and B players hire C
players which is like good people hired
good I don't think that that's that
informative I think a lot of the time
the problem is you don't actually know
and sometimes you're like trying to
figure out how good someone is if you
think they were good you won't have
hired them but the heuristic of only
hiring people who you would work for
tends to be pretty good I think because
that you know like I would not work for
this person then okay I'm not gonna like
stretch just because I need to fill a
role today you just watched two amazing
clips of Mark Zuckerberg take the next
three minutes and sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]